a recent article from CNBC said this as
coronavirus forces millions of people to
work remotely the US economy may have
reached a tipping point in favor of
working from home have you found
yourself working from home during this
time you know whether you're an employee
working remotely whether you just
recently found yourself quarantined or
whether you're an entrepreneur that is
building a side hustle or has been
working from home for a long time now
learning how to be productive get things
done and stay motivated from home is
critical and for me over the past five
years I've ran a small business from my
home over the past ten I've had side
hustles that have always done video
editing and had a home office or a
corner of a living room and I've had to
figure out what are the best practices
and the best principles of staying
productive you know I've studied high
performance and productivity of the top
billionaires and artists and CEOs to
learn their secrets and I've personally
battled procrastination and I've made a
lot of mistakes on the journey so in
this video or podcast episode I'm going
to be breaking down 10 tips for staying
productive and working remotely and
we're getting into it right now podcast
the number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm shawn kennel
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening welcome
this show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content notice and
the latest money-making strategies
working right now online so whether you
want to grow your YouTube channel or you
want to maximize video across all of
social media this podcast is for you
welcome back to the think marketing show
I'm so pumped that you're here whether
you are watching on YouTube or listening
on Spotify Google Apple or your favorite
platform I'm so grateful you're here and
today I couldn't think of a more
important topic during this time right
now we're gonna be talking about how to
work from home and 10 specific tips
they're gonna help you get more done
because here's the deal you need to get
stuff done
right now I know that you might have
found yourself in financial hardship
maybe you've been laid off or maybe
you're just working remotely and trying
to figure out how to keep your boss
happy we're gonna be talking about some
actionable tips that are really really
gonna help you you know a couple things
I've seen that have been happening in
culture right now is zoom video
communications you know the video
conferencing software their stock has
gone up almost 30 percent in the last
month as the market has continued to
crash in other ways their stock has gone
up and soared and you know I think it's
pretty obvious why because all the
sudden everyone's like man how do I have
these virtual staff meetings how do I
actually connect my teams I've seen
churches and nonprofits meeting with
their staff and hosting small groups
using software like that so we are
seeing this massive circumstantial push
into remote remote working you know
Oracle Apple Google are among the
largest companies right now who've
restricted travel and asked their
employees to work remote remotely as a
precaution against the novel corona
virus and so in this time no matter
whether you're an employer and employee
or unemployed or an entrepreneur this
information matters this episode might
be the most important episode you ever
listened to hear on the think marketing
podcast and so a couple tips before we
get into the main content employers this
is the time to really focus on educating
and equipping your team to be productive
when working remotely like if you have
any kind of team any kind of virtual
assistants you got to maybe share this
episode with them pass this information
along because this could be entirely new
I mean it's not that people don't want
to do a good job it's that all the
sudden they find themselves like wait a
minute
I got all these distractions and now I'm
at home and I've never done this before
and so employers be thinking about
resources training reinventing
yourselves how you gonna meet how you
gonna keep your team inspired how you
gonna keep them motivated employees you
need to learn this do not take your job
for granted maybe you found that you are
working from home right now
it's not a guarantee that you're gonna
have a job tomorrow so you want to be in
the top percentile of producing results
for your employer how can you connect
your work to the bottom line at our team
we call those IPAs not the beer we call
them IPAs income producing activities
connect your actions to being peak
productive when working remotely and
we're gonna share tips in just a second
and if you're an entrepreneur or you're
unemployed and so now you're considering
entrepreneurship and making money on the
side or building a business right now
your life freakin depends on this like
if you're an entrepreneur you don't have
anyone to motivate you you got to
motivate yourself you don't have anyone
to keep you focused it depends on you
it's all on you and so you have to find
a way to make sure that your days are
productive focused and that you get
things done when working remotely so
this applies to all of us so let's dive
into the tips and the first one is start
right if you're gonna stay productive
when working remotely you've got to
start right to me that means starting
with a powerful morning routine now I
want to recommend a book and this is
probably a topic for a full dedicated
episode because morning routines there's
a lot of nuances I've studied the
morning routines of billionaires and top
CEOs and top athletes and a lot of
people that have accomplished great
things have had a powerful prizefighter
morning routine and so the book is the
miracle morning and check out the
audible or the the physical book or
ebook well of course link that up in the
show notes and that's a book that
changed my life years ago where I
realized man I have to get up and get in
the right mindset I have to get into the
right you know headspace
I got a guard in my heart my soul make
sure I'm ready for the day
you know you might be waking up right
now literally with anxiety and
depression staring you right in the face
like a weight on your chest you got to
fight that thing and a strong morning
routine can shift your mentality and get
you into the right state to take on you
or day I get up and I look at my goals I
get up I pray I read my Bible I get up I
read another book or I listened to it on
audible some days pretty much every
other day I'll go on a run and most days
I try to do a stretch just stretching to
just get limber get hydrated I drink
some coffee
and so really write down maybe just a
morning routine and commit to it if you
want to have a great day working
remotely and specifically on your
morning routine I like to also leave
with a definition of these three things
who are the people that I need to
connect with today who do I need to
follow up with and Who am I waiting on
to follow up with me this is the three
P's what are the most important projects
that I have going on today and then what
are my priorities maybe I'm working on a
project right now I am rebuilding our
signature course called video ranking
Academy we're actually just about to do
a live recording it's absolutely
incredible I'm fired up for it that's
one of my most important projects and so
I I every day have to say okay am i
blocking time to work on that project
and then priorities today what are like
the three things that if you don't get
anything else done you got to get these
three priorities done today you want to
know at the end of your morning routine
the people the priorities and the
projects and a quick tip for starting
right is don't check email or social
media first you know one of the best
ways to mess up your mind to mess up
your day is to check in on someone
else's agenda
I've heard people define your email
inbox as a collection of other people's
agendas I'm not saying don't ever check
email I'm saying your morning should
belong to you what is your goal your
vision what are you focusing on first
and getting and then checking in with
everybody else
once you have tackled self-care really
and and guarding your own heart get your
own confidence up but also maybe even
your own creative projects for the first
few hours of the day before you check in
on everything else you need to do and of
course that depends on maybe you're like
I'm an employer I do have to check in
first thing well then or an employee
well then yeah do whatever you have to
do but as an entrepreneur
I want to get a lot of my creative work
done before I check in on other things
and then another really practical tip
get dressed I know it's kind of exciting
that you're working from home so you can
you know we joke about it when you are
like an online entrepreneur that's like
man I can do business in my boxers but
I've kind of learned this that being in
my pajamas three days in a row and not
showering and not shaving is the
quickest way that I get into the wrong
mindset and depression I'm not kidding
right I've noticed that just my overall
confidence goes down and that I I
stopped having unstoppable confidence
because I'm not getting up and dressing
like a professional therefore I don't
really think of myself as much as a
professional and then I don't get
professional results
I've worked from home for years now
people even wonder why why even get up
and get dressed and like wear something
different it's because because it's for
me it's for me to say I'm gonna put
myself together and it's an outward
symbol of the inward reality that I want
to experience the man I'm gonna crush
this day and I'm gonna enter and attack
this day like a professional tip number
two if you're gonna start right number
one you need to start the night before
tip number two start the night before
this means if possible plan your next
day the day before because if you wake
up like me man you're groggy and you go
okay what am I supposed to do today you
know what and you might even what are my
priorities today I don't know I got so
much on my plate I'm not even sure what
I'm supposed to do next when you
actually go to sleep knowing generally
outlining what your next day's going to
be like then you can attack the day with
so much more effectiveness when working
remotely of course this also makes this
an is influenced by your decisions the
night before I've learned that you know
maybe you're like man I work remotely
now I got all the flexibility we hang
out the kids a little bit late stay up a
little later
you know binge watch some Netflix shows
you know have a couple drinks you know
read into the night play some games
whatever it is next thing you know
you're behind on sleep next thing you
know you're behind in your
nutrition and you're gonna carry how
what you did the night before into the
next morning I know this isn't maybe
even sexy or encouraging right you're
like dude this sounds awful bro but like
you got to double down in discipline if
you want to have a really effective day
and that's gonna be influenced by the
night before so for me I want to get
enough sleep for me it makes I think
about what I eat especially during the
week you know during the week when I
want to be most productive during if you
will work days and then on the weekend
it's a little bit different maybe that's
time to if you will have your cheat day
or or whatever and and so just start the
night before how can you set yourself up
the night before for the next day this
could also mean setting your workout
clothes out you know yesterday I put
down my running gear is like a whole
bunch of things now I want to make sure
that my I know where my Apple watch is
so for tracking the run wear my
headphones are at so they're charged I
got my running playlist I listened to a
lot of EDM and high paced like you know
DJs and drum and bass music when I run
and stuff like that and I got a runner's
belt cuz I bring my phone with me and I
got beat if it's a little bit chilly
outside here in Las Vegas
I got like running or legging things I
got a little neon jacket so I don't get
hit by a car I got the hats there's all
these different items here's what here's
what I've learned if I have it put those
things out and gathered them the night
before
sometimes I'm wandering the house 40
minutes trying to sip some coffee
where's the runners Bell I have no idea
my phone my my headphones are dead so
I'm like let me let these charged up for
a while and then I just sit around
waiting and get distracted on other
things you've been there I'm sure I've
been there think about how you can set
up your next day for success by starting
the night before that will help you
number three close the door
I think this is a symbol of protecting
your focus if you're gonna get things
done and you're gonna you know be
productive when working remotely and
working from home you got to protect
your focus as much as possible all day
long this is gonna affect your profits
by the way why do I want to be
productive Shaun so that you get a race
so that you don't lose your
why do I know why I want to be
productive Shawn because as an
entrepreneur your actions need to be
producing results for your bottom line
well I don't want to what be productive
so you can get results and the only way
you're going to be able to do that is if
you protect your focus so for me closing
the door is actually a big deal
I like having doors closed in my home
office because then I can't see out of
my peripheral what's going on out there
shuts down a little bit of the noise
that's happening out there right so
that's just something practical for me
what do you need to do to guard your
focus now as a disclaimer in this whole
episode I don't have kids yet my wife
Sonia and I've got a baby on the way
we're in the second trimester and so you
might be like dude this sounds nice bro
like but I got seven kids that are
screaming and swinging off the
chandeliers you got to do you and figure
out your routine in your system and
we're actually gonna be doing a
follow-up episode where Heather Taurus
is gonna share her tips that come from
an entirely different perspective I
talked to her about this episode and she
was like that's a pretty I idealistic
Shawn you know I have a dream that I
could do your same routine as you but
she did say this man you got to
communicate with your family you need to
set boundaries with your family with
your kids work is work and it needs to
be scheduled you know I don't know how
you can go to your employer and say you
know like it was just tough my kid you
know throughout the day and I get it you
might you got to do what you got to do
but your employer is paying you to work
eight hours you got to work eight hours
even if you're working at home and it's
gonna be interesting to see with all
this remote work that I really believe
some are going to actually kind of fail
during this season if they can't figure
this out because at some point employers
are gonna measure results and so work is
work and it needs to be scheduled so
that means communicating with your
husband or your partner or your nanny or
your daycare or your kids if they're a
little bit older and saying look I
you're adults you know they're like
seven or eight I don't know she's gonna
be speaking more to this but you've got
to close your door and protect your
focus you know I was a director of
communications at a church and for me
that meant that one I had a
team members that I had to manage but I
was also a creator myself so I had to
edit get things done and because of that
I noticed that there was a trend
happening where might I would constantly
be having my team just come into my
office throughout the day sometimes
every 15 minutes every 30 minutes and
what I learned was that all of those
interruptions would shut down my
productivity and would take me a long
time to get reengaged in the work in
fact it's actually been studied that
employers lose 2.1 hours a day to their
workers due to interruptions and
distractions that's 546 hours annually
and so let's say you're making 20 bucks
an hour
that's $11,000 a year that just gets
burnt up by interruptions and
distractions now it's not that you
obviously have to communicate with your
team if you have a team but what I
learned was I had to actually set
boundaries to guard my focus with my
team and say look we're either going to
talk about all of this all at once or
you're you could send me an email or
send me a text but you can't just barge
into the office and constantly interrupt
my focus and my flow cuz I am trying to
get things done and so I put a sign up
and you know it was kind of joked about
it was kind of mocked and whatnot but it
was like just like in a radio station on
air like don't come in here I am working
my friend if you want to be productive
at home entrepreneur a content creator
you got a guard your focus and when you
do you're gonna get more done and when
you get more done you're gonna have more
outputs and when you have more outputs
you're gonna have more results and when
you get more results you're gonna make
more money and when you make more money
you're gonna be able to provide for your
family but it all comes back to the
discipline the decision the
communication you got to set the
boundaries up and you got to figure out
your life to close the door and protect
your focus tip number four is create an
inspiring work space create an inspiring
work space you know it's hard to get up
and want to get motivated if you're
working someplace that you hate and I
mean like your environment your desk
your computer the decor if it's super
s-see you know it can just be
distracting and not inspiring now you
might be like well Sean you know I don't
really have much space my office is a
corner of a living room I don't even
have a dedicated home office you got a
do you but how can you here's the
question level up your workspace how can
you you know for me I got a little
humidifier I put some doTERRA essential
oils in there and it's that breathe and
it kind of gives me that like mint kind
of gets the air your channels your
breathing opened up I start my day so
I'm thinking about you know the
fragrance there I happen to be by a
window and it's a blessing to have an
office where I can close the door and I
got a view of the backyard so I'm
thinking about natural light when I
didn't have natural light I'm thinking
about lighting I like having a lot of
lights on if it's dingy dark smelly you
know discouraging uninspiring that's
gonna be hard to get your best work done
so how can you create an inspiring
workspace wherever you are especially if
you're new to working remotely you know
might be something you chip away at you
think about how can you rearrange things
rearrange rooms get some furniture
change some furniture create an
inspiring workspace and tip number five
is keep your workspace clean you know
it's been proven that clutter reduces
productivity it increases anxiety it
will you won't get as much done and
you'll the stuff you do get done you
won't feel as good while you're doing it
you won't know what to prioritize and so
I'll admit I do have a rather large
basically almost our entire second floor
of our house is kind of business
workspace and my loft right now where we
shoot videos and we have some stuff it's
it's not decluttered it's it's it's it's
not good at all I don't want you to see
it but my office I keep it clean that
place where I work where I'm focused
where I'm journaling taking notes making
my battle plan and my battle board for
the day where I'm recording videos I got
to keep that clean because I know that
it's gonna help me stay productive when
I'm working from home well hey I hope
you've been getting value out of this I
got five more tips for you but if you're
watching this on YouTube smash like and
if you're listening to
it's somewhere else and you can rate a
review and you haven't rated or reviewed
the think marketing podcasts yet please
do that man you sharing this with
somebody maybe a leader an employer an
entrepreneur that needs to hear it means
the world to me in our team so please do
that I hope you've been getting value
and I want to ask you you know leave a
comment below or leave a review you know
what have you learned here and what do
you need to do in your life for your
business - maybe guard your focus as far
as working remotely what could you do
different the night before you know how
how could you improve your Moni morning
routine can you close your door make a
sign communicate with your family
protect your focus what could you add to
your workspace this week that would
inspire you and you know does your
workspace just need to be cleaned up and
do that today and all of a sudden it
might bring a fresh wave of energy a
fresh wave of motivation and help you
really tackle the next step well hey tip
number six is kill distractions
this might mean turning off social media
in fact I recommend it now
you might be like what the heck are you
talking about bro this is the think
marketing show our job is social media I
gotta be on Instagram I gotta be
scrolling and commenting back and
answering DMS I gotta be posting on
LinkedIn no I get it but you need to be
doing that on your own time in your own
terms and you need to be doing that in a
pre-planned productive way you know it's
interesting that iPhones these days now
tell us our screen time at the end of
the week and that can sometimes be a
discouraging metric now if you're typing
out a caption on Instagram you're
getting something done well that's
amazing if you're shooting a video and
your screen is open shooting videos
that's awesome but if you're just on
social media scrolling you could just be
wasting your time and look it's
diminishing your willpower it's taking
your energy it's causing you probably
have FOMO or comparison it's probably
not helping I've found that a lot of
times when I go scrolling I don't
usually feel better afterwards
and so how can you kill distractions
how can you interrupt your interruptions
and you may want to try one of these
social media apps that can actually help
you stay productive we'll put a link to
an article that has ten different apps
that block social media sites or news
feeds and things like that some of the
apps are called like off time freedom
app block and this is where you with
wisdom look ahead and say yeah it's not
helping me to just be scrolling on
Instagram yes in the morning for that
one hour I'm gonna shoot that live
stream do that post reply to people I'm
gonna be answering DMS to build my
business in the afternoon but I don't
need to be scrolling all day consider
maybe using some apps to support your
discipline in your willpower I've
learned that if I there's a million
things I want to look at I can open my
email inbox oh look there's a sale at my
favorite online store oh look there's
some cool person doing a webinar doing a
training if you need to learn that skill
right now and that's a webinar you need
to watch good but you don't just need
another shiny object in your life or
business you need to be focusing on the
next right step for you you know and so
take back your time and kill
distractions interrupt your
interruptions if you know that yeah in
the afternoon I'm a little tired little
groggy and so I just go to my phone turn
on an app that blocks your social media
apps during certain hours and then
you're like boom you know you get off
work and it's seven or eight do whatever
you want you know you need to have you
time and you need to you know embrace
that stuff I'm talking about staying
productive working remotely for your
employer as an entrepreneur because
stayin distracted on a bunch of gist
what may even kind it you justify it cuz
you're like yo you know I'm researching
I'm watching more YouTube videos on tips
how many more tips do you need like I'm
watching YouTube I know you need some
more strategies but you also need a
press record like you need to punch fear
in the face punch procrastination in the
face and impress record and so kill
distractions tip number seven eat smart
and stay hydrated
Sean this is the worst podcast of all
time you
your bro you're just a buzzkill I'm just
trying to help man and I know this that
when I don't eat smart throughout my day
if I eat too heavy I get tired in the
afternoon if I binge on snacks and some
candy or some too much sugar it kills my
energy especially during crisis
man I need creative power in my mind
more than ever before during crisis I
need to have my best work when I sit
down and batch record some podcasts or
batch record some videos I gotta show up
so I can be present so I can be vibrant
so I can have energy and if I eat the
wrong things or if I'm not hydrated then
I'm not gonna be able to show up for you
you gotta show up for work at home you
gotta show up with your best energy so
whatever that means for you you know
typically a little insight into my
process is I eat pretty lean mainly five
days a week
super lean breakfast if not intermittent
fasting and I'll drink some bone broth
and some green juice and coffee and
maybe a protein bar and then maybe I'll
eat around lunch or twelve or one and
I'll eat it's actually called bitchin
sauce it's an all almond dip with you
know those like red and yellow and
orange peppers and maybe like some salad
and that's just my routine you got to
figure out yours and I eat very little
cuz I found that kind of being in a
fasted state keeps my energy high keeps
my focus sharp and then it's like yo off
work
hanging out with wifey let's go let's
order out let's cook something let's get
crazy you know but if you want to get
stuff done during the day you got to be
intentional with what you put in your
body and then stay hydrated drink as
much water as you can I don't think you
could possibly drink too much water well
Shawn it's gonna make me need to like go
to the bathroom all day that's probably
a good thing because from sitting at
home you're gonna be sitting and you're
sedentary so if you got to get up and
constantly use the restroom good oh my
gosh how awful would it be that you're
constantly flushing toxins out of your
body that you're constantly resetting
your system and I found that a lot of
times you know I do like coffee and I
drink usually 1 2 cups in the morning
and then maybe
before my coffee curfew at 1:00 or 2:00
if I go past that I know it's really on
and it's getting lit man it's getting
crazy if I'm drinking coffee like 4:30
I'm like it's this I got it I'm grinding
right now but I try to you know adhere
to some of those things and I've learned
though that when my energy begins to dip
before I reach for caffeine it might be
better to reach for water because if I
make if I haven't been drinking water
I start getting dehydrated it crashes my
energy and actually I can recover a lot
of that energy by simply being hydrated
all right hey tip number eight is then
move and take breaks if you're working
remotely you're working from home you're
probably sitting at a desk and if you're
working in an office you're probably
sitting at a desk now I know we have all
different jobs and maybe your job has
you on your feet maybe you're delivering
packages driving around if you're
driving you're probably sitting but a
sedentary lifestyle is not good for any
of us and so we have to be intentional
to move for me I work from home in Las
Vegas in our neighborhood I like to call
them water walks and I try to take 1 to
3 of those a day and where I just do a
little loop around this one area of our
neighborhood and if possible bring water
with me and I'm doing two things I'm
getting hydrated as I just take a walk
moving just means maybe get up and
stretch and best practice from all the
research that I've done is showed that
you actually kind of want to do that
about every 50 minutes now I get in a
flow and when I'm planning videos when
I'm building out courses when I'm
shooting stuff a lot of times I'll grind
consistently and I won't really take a
break but I'll also notice I'll fuel
that later and what I've learned is that
usually for every 50 minutes of work you
want to stand up stretch drink some
water
you know release tension and set
intention stretch out a little and I'll
feel it release the tension be like okay
man that phone call sucked you know
whatever whoever you were on with or
whatever and you're like all right what
I got to do next I got to crush this
next task this next thing release
tension set in tension and potentially
take a walk you might also want to think
about investing in a standing desk
we'll throw a link in the show notes -
we've done a couple different videos on
standing desks now unfortunately I don't
have this in my main office I have it in
my loft and when it's clean I got to
clean the clutter all a lot of times
work for my laptop out there because
from standing or being able to sit and
stand that can help you just think about
practical ways to get your body moving
because when you got the blood flow you
know this is why I love running because
as an entrepreneur when I'm running my
brain gets fired up I start getting
ideas I start solving problems and I
know also this is why when I'm just
sitting at my desk and I'm need to plan
out I do some keyword research I got
four videos to plan and I just stared a
blank page like ain't nothing flowing
ain't nothing coming out of my brain
probably because I don't have any oxygen
in my blood I'm dehydrated and I have
been sitting around all day how crazy is
it that once you start to move ideas
begin to flow again Steve Jobs was
famous for doing walking meetings with
his team he'd be like let's go we're
gonna have a meeting let's walk around
the Apple complex and so you got to move
you got to get going and that'll
activate your brain your energy come on
your emotions your creativity there's a
fluid stance board it's like this little
surfboard you balance on and you can
stand on at a standing desk it just
keeps your legs engaged and it keeps
with all these micro movements look for
some of these tools and we'll link to
some of those things in the show notes
that have really helped me and I believe
will help you as well hey tip number
nine is do not multitask this one's
crazy y'all do not multitask so I found
an article in an infographic that only
2% of people can successfully multitask
so look that's probably not you write
the remaining 98% of us multitasking
does more harm then it does good and so
what we think when it comes to
multitasking is we think oh you know
what I'm going to be you know answering
these emails over here while I'm doing
this thing over here or I'm gonna have
chat open while I do this and
my friends is a myth listen to this
focusing on more than one thing
decreases your productivity by 40% and
lowers your IQ by 10 points according to
Harvard Business Review you know look at
this that is an equivalent of missing an
entire night of sleep and it's twice the
effect of smoking marijuana
if you multitask yeah yo bro what do you
been taking man you're like dude you
look like you got some good stuff no
broad just been multitasking man I'm
just like I'm just like lit right you
know what I mean
like that's crazy your IQ goes down your
productivity goes down when you multi
test you might say no that's not me I
can do multiple things at once science
says you can't
and if 40% my friend
so you could double your productivity
you want to get more videos done you
want to finish that course finish that
book finish that ebook create that thing
stop multitasking you can increase your
productivity by 40% if you do that and
not lower your IQ so so let's talk about
this practically this is also why that
same stat of 2.1 hours a day are lost by
the average employee because of
interruptions and distractions when you
don't shut off notifications on your
phone that's a tip when you don't shut
off and interrupt your interruptions of
getting phone calls getting face times
now you might be like I work at a call
center Sean well okay well then that's
your job you that's what you're focusing
on cool but especially I'm talking to
you entrepreneur I'm talking to you
person who needs to produce results and
has some autonomy and freedom working
from home you've got to really say if
you want to accomplish deep work you
know what I'm editing for these next
couple hours and that's all I'm doing
the door shut
video editing software open I'm gonna
get this video done and don't you agree
with me that a lot of the projects we
work on if we really put our mind to it
and we put a time limit on how long that
thing was gonna take we probably could
get it done
and half the time you know what I mean
like there's times where we've learned I
got a whole day to edit this video it's
gonna take all day but if you got to get
it done by noon then it's gonna get done
by noon you know one way or another and
so stay focused avoid multitasking or
kill it all together and really be
careful with technology the article
talks about technology is encouraging us
to be more fruitless in multitasking you
got notifications coming on being
someone's going live you know the cool
thing about live streaming is that you
can go back and watch it on demand and
so I typically don't actually like
watching people live thank God if you
watch some of our live streams and I
love it when we could be there live and
engage but for me I love consuming
content from my favorite creators but I
prefer to go back and watch the replay
to me that's on demand right on my time
when I schedule it not and I get tempted
in the middle of the day I get a text
message from some of the online courses
and the programs I'm subscribed to I'm
like oh dang I want to go watch that but
then I got to ask myself what do I need
to do next
what's my team waiting on what's my most
important task right now what's my most
important priority and then I can say
instead I'm gonna calendar block the
time to go back and consume that content
I'm gonna miss out on it I can do that
tomorrow or at the end of the next day
put it on my calendar to get my journal
write and do it when I choose not
letting myself being interrupted or
letting it potentially play in the
background and think that I'm gonna get
a bunch of information out of this while
also doing this thing over here kill
multitasking come on and you're gonna
double your productivity well I got one
more tip for you and then we've got our
kind of shout outs at the end and a
couple cool announcements and so
definitely stick around but tip number
10 is give yourself some grace you might
have felt this episode was a little bit
of you know hardcore and I hope that's
what you're here for is you know a
little bit of coaching in terms of being
productive as an entrepreneur here at
the think marketing show we're here to
help you we want your profits to go up
your results to go up and for you to get
more done not just for you but for the
team that you're going to build in the
future the team you have now
but you got to give yourself grace if
you're new to working from home new
habits are gonna take time I just
outlined a set of practices and kind of
a lifestyle I've built over the last
decade I've been obsessed with how to
experience peak productivity get the
most done why because what's it for why
be so hyper productive so that when I'm
off I'm off so that I can have the
freedom to go out and experience
stress-free time with my wife Sonya
where we can take the Jeep and drive
through the desert or we can just head
off on a road trip or I can go
snowboarding in Park City or just I can
take the weekend and play some video
games like I want to be able to really
enjoy my time off therefore I want to
get as much done when I'm working but
these new habits take time so give
yourself grace you know on board like
getting interrupted you know and and I
also I'm not trying to sit here on some
kind of pedestal and say like I don't
get interrupted anymore or that I don't
just find myself in a Instagram you know
scrolling frenzy and I also don't find
myself I don't really want to do that
next project so instead I'm just gonna
like surf social media and justify it
because I'm doing research no no we all
need to give ourselves grace these
habits take time and no matter how hard
you try some days just won't go well
like some days are awesome some days the
interruptions don't come or there's just
a grace to it and a flow to it some days
there isn't and so you got to just take
each and every day day by day and try to
get up the next day and learn from the
lessons the prior day taught you and
I've also learned that interruptions
could be okay you know if you do have
autonomy and you're your own
entrepreneur you can take the middle of
the day to spend some time with your
kids you can you know if your spouse
needs something just go to lunch with
them and it wasn't planned that's the
beauty of running your own business and
sometimes that might be the best
decision in the moment and so I'm not
suggesting so much hyper productivity
that you don't even see the opportunity
in interruptions sometimes a call will
come through it wasn't planned but I see
who it is and I am
in a 90 minute conversation what's very
important was very strategic or it's
just catching up you know sometimes it
you do need to connect with friends you
need to connect with family but if
you're an employee last time I checked
if you were in the office you didn't
really have the freedom to just be like
you know what I need to do to do a
two-hour conversation with my mom I
think your boss to be like bro you're at
work how about you do the call after
work so you really got to juggle this
work his work but some interruptions
could be strategic they could be God
putting somebody in your step it could
be a divine setup or it could be a
distraction so try to weigh those figure
those things out expect and give
yourself grace in the whole time and let
me just say that this is literally one
of the biggest skills not just for now
not just for during this crisis in this
time of you know being quarantined but
this is where the world is going in the
future
there's gonna be more remote workers
there's gonna be you're gonna find
yourself probably building a remote team
maybe right now you have a day job but
you're working on your dream job and
you're looking to build a business like
we've built here at think media you know
we want to help 10,000 people create a
full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with online video we get to work from
home and we do have freedom we can do
what we want when we want where we want
with who we want we can spend time with
the people that matter most to us and
take off a couple days during the week
or go snowboard for three days in Park
City but by the way the only reason we
can do that is because of yesterday's
discipline and action and productivity
but you got to develop the skill first
of all you got to lead yourself manage
yourself and get dialed in personally
but eventually you're gonna need to pass
these skills on to try to figure out how
to build a small team or to build a crew
that is gonna build that business that
online business that freedom business
that maybe is your goal that you want to
do I've learned that again a lot of
youtubers sometimes break down at a
certain scale they got some money going
they even got like a six-figure income
going but they can't scale their
business because they can't figure out
how to get teams motivated
unified remote workers and communicate
it's a new skill set and so I hope this
episode was a blessing to you I hope it
probably challenged you a little bit but
I really believe that when you work on
these skills when you work on mastering
your daily productivity plan when you
develop the habits necessary for you to
stay productive when working remotely
and when you also help your team do it
and pass this along to anybody that
needs to hear about it that we can take
more ground that we can make a greater
impact that we could generate more
profits serve more people and make a
greater difference in people's lives and
the world from our homes with this
information so there are some incredible
things coming up here at think media and
I just want to inform you about a few
first of all we are so excited for
groweth video live 2020 that's right
this September in Las Vegas what does
the future hold Shawn we don't know for
sure but we are moving full speed ahead
I've got a couple friends of mine who've
you know had to reschedule their events
they have some happening in August so we
are fully confident that people are
gonna be able to fly here in Las Vegas
and man we've got a crazy lineup of
speakers
if you haven't got your ticket go to
growth video live.com you're gonna get
the best rate for the conference at the
website right now and now it just might
be the time to grab your tickets a lot
of times you can get tickets that are
refundable or you can get travel
insurance just in case for some reason
this thing was super crazy and went for
a super long time and so you're gonna
have that flexibility and no matter what
we're gonna be delivering value we're
all in for growth video live here in
Vegas but we'll adapt and pivot to to
delivering online value and turning it
into a virtual summit with extra
coaching or extra benefits or whatever
you just know that we got your back
regardless so get your tickets for grow
with video live check out all of the
speakers on the website and if you
haven't done the giveaway make sure to
rate and review the podcast and follow
the steps at the think not the at think
marketing show calm and that's going to
take you it's going to tell you a few
steps that you can do or all you have to
do is on Apple podcast leave a review of
the podcast rate it
and then you just have to take a
screenshot of it and email it to us all
those details are at think marketing
show comm and you'll be entered to win
two free tickets to grow with video live
with Heather Taurus
Omar LT Cory Chris Ducker Pat Flynn
chalene johnson Pete Fergus content bug
Vanessa Lau Stephanie Liu man it's gonna
be amazing and so definitely enter that
giveaway and all those links plus
everything else we talked about in this
episode will be in the show notes of
this episode and in the YouTube
description hey remember what is your
next action step you know after this
episode you might have been like man I
got a couple action steps a couple
things that I could do to maybe boost my
productivity and get more done at home
and while I'm working remotely but put
it into practice you know you don't
develop 48 habits all at once but what
is the one that can move the needle most
for you maybe it's gonna be downloading
one of those apps like off time freedom
or app block so that you can stop the
scroll and actually interrupt your
interruptions during the day maybe it's
creating an inspiring work space you
know times are tough right now but I
think you still want to invest in
yourself your business your education
and maybe your work space maybe it's you
know thinking about some tools some tech
getting your live stream set up set up
getting some artwork on the wall getting
something out there get some succulents
whatever your vibe is whatever your
thing is maybe it's that what is your
next action step after listening to the
podcast let me know and shout out to the
review of the week this week again these
reviews are over on Apple podcast thank
you so much for rating and reviewing the
show the support has been overwhelming
and amazing USC for life says this great
content but even better and here's the
review Sean is the real deal after years
of watching his many YouTube videos I
reached out to him to have him on the
start startup story podcast to share his
journey he is equally amazing in person
I am so stoked to see Sean and the team
bring their brilliance to the podcast
format Sean and the think team are laser
focused on delivering real value in
everything they do
go crush it team think man I appreciate
that USC for life thank you for rating
and reviewing the podcast and thank you
if you've shared this with somebody
liked it reviewed it left a comment on
youtube anything it all appreciates you
so much and finally I just want to
encourage you this week to go out and
stay focused on your goals make your
vision so clear that your fears become
irrelevant punch fear in the face get
your goals clear and then wake up every
day and hustle work in remotely hustle
working from home think about your why
why are you doing this who are you
fighting for reasons come before results
reasons come first results come second
when you remember that you're fighting
for your family you're fighting for your
team you're fighting for your future
you're fighting for a better world
you're fighting because you're still you
still got a job and you have sensitivity
to those that have lost their job and
you just are fighting because you're
grateful for the gift of life that God
has given all of us think about that
this week punch fear in the face get
after your goals and we will see you or
you'll hear you or us in the next think
marketing podcast appreciate you talk
soon